>>Chris Barbic: You know
it's funny 'cause if you talk
at reform circles now, I mean, the
big buzz word is "human capital."
You know? This is all
about human capital.
And you know, we've been
doing this for ten years now,
and I think we knew from day
one that that was the key.
I mean you got to have a great
teacher in every classroom and,
you know, the rest
of the stuff's great.
You know? Computers
and stuff, and things--
that's all dandy, but if you
don't have a great teacher
in the classroom, it
doesn't really matter.
At a lot of places, everyone sort
of writes off the first
few years as well.
You know, that's when you learn
how to be a great teacher.
And you're not really a
good teacher until, like,
your third or fourth year.
Well, like, that's great for the
teacher, but they got three years
of kids that are going through their
classroom, and you know, that's two
or three years of bad instruction.
I mean that sets kids back forever.
It's about discipline, and teaching
our kids how to make good decisions,
and be disciplined people,
and it's about love, you know?
And I think it's that balance
of, you know, tough and love.
And I think our best teachers--
they're like alchemists, you know?
They can put those
two things together,
and they know when to put their
arm around a kid and, you know,
give them the pep talk and show
some love, and they know when to,
you know, I won't say get in
a kid's face, but you know,
they know when to raise their
voice and get a kid's attention.
And I think, you know, our best
teachers can bring those two things
together, and I think that's
really the culture of this place is
that we want to hold
each other accountable.
We want to push each
other to be great,
but we want to do it in a loving way.
And so from there, we've
tried to set up systems that,
you know, allow us to do that.
I mean, the basic one's just the
size of the school and making sure
that this isn't, you know, a school
with 3,000 kids where, you know,
students go from classroom to
classroom and maybe, you know,
once a week someone calls
them by their first name.
That's not this place.
I love doing the home visits.
So the home visits are when, you
know, after a kid's, you know,
name's been picked in a lottery,
go and visit their house and we go
through the contract with
them and their parents,
and we talk about this is what
it means to be a student at YES.
And you know, the reason I love this
is, you know, we have 4,000 kids
on our waitlist, so when you go
to those, when you go to a house,
I mean that family really
has won the lottery.
I mean that kid's-- this is going
to be his legitimate pathway,
or her legitimate pathway
to go to college,
and really change the
dynamics of that entire family.
So it's fun to be there because,
you know, they're excited.
And the contract, I
think, it's symbolic.
It's -- you know, what we
want parents to understand is
that this has got to be
a team effort, you know?
If it's just us wanting this
thing and them not really caring,
and the kid really not wanting to
be here, this isn't going to work.
And if it's just the kid wanting to
be here and we're not doing our job,
and the parents aren't supporting
them, it's not going to work.
So part of it is just saying look,
this is a three-legged stool.
It's us, it's your kid, and it's
you, and if we work together
for the next seven years, your
kid's going to be able to go
to any college they want to.
The signage and the
messaging and, you know,
when you walk into a classroom,
I mean there's stuff
up all over the walls.
You know, all that's intentional.
When I was a teacher,
I mean my goal was even
if the kids aren't paying
attention to me and they're looking
around the room or daydreaming, I
want them learning something, right?
But there really has to be kind
of a marketing campaign every day
around why are you here, what
this is going to lead to,
and why college is really
important, and the kind of people
that we want our kids to be.
The part of it is just making sure
that kids are getting
the right messages
because when they're not
here, they're bombarded
with a whole other set of them.
You know, whether it's on TV,
or from their, you know, peers,
or just being in the neighborhood.
And so if we're not aware of
that and trying to, you know,
fight that with positive messaging
here, we're fooling ourselves.
So student council basically came
up with these things, you know,
and you know, we tweaked it a
little bit, and so when we looked
at it we said, "Well look, you
know, some of these are behaviors
and some of these are values."
So we kind of divided them
up into what we call the
YES prep, "Thinks and Acts."
And so this, along with the core
values, have really become kind
of the, like, the cornerstone
for the culture of the school.
And so I feel like, you know,
one of my jobs and the jobs
of the leaderships across this
organization is to make sure
that we're living those signs,
we're living those values,
and that we are walking,
breathing examples of the kind
of people we want our kids to be.
There was a time when, you know,
the post office swore they could
not deliver a package overnight.
Next-day air was impossible.
And, you know, FedEx got to a
certain size, and UPS came along
and they started to grow,
and guess what happened?
You know, FedEx figured out-- or
the post office figured out how
to do next-day air, and that's what
we're going to do to the district.
We're not going to replace the
district, but we're going to get
to a certain size where
we're going to force HISD
and other districts
in Houston to improve.
They're going to have to figure out
how to deliver a package over night,
and what delivering a
package overnight means,
not making any excuses
why kids who live
in certain neighborhoods can't
all be prepared to go to college.
It's kind of human nature.
Like when the first thing you
want to do is kind of, you know--
I call it picking up the magnifying
glass before you pick up the mirror,
and you know, instead of picking
up the mirror and saying, "Okay.
What are we doing wrong?"
You know, you pick up the magnifying
glass and you're trying to figure
out all the reasons why this thing's
not really working or it's smoke
and mirrors, or you know, they
can do things that we can't.
And, you know, I get that.
I mean it's human nature.
And it does create some tension,
and I think what we've tried to do
by opening up the doors and
saying, "Look, here it is."
You know, it goes back to the
transparency thing we talked
about a little while ago.
I mean this is who we are.
Like we're not going to apologize
for it, and if there's things
that we can do that you can't, I
mean my question is well how come?
I mean we're a public school
too, you're a public school.
Like why can't you do those things?
And no one's really ever been able
to give me a really good answer
for that, and you know,
we want to share.
I mean it's in our best interest
for all the schools in
Houston to be great.
And you know, we don't win by
getting to be the darlings, you know,
of the media or whatever because
we've gotten great results.
We win if more schools are great
because of what we're doing.
And if we can be the proof point or
the experiment, or the Petri dish,
or the R and D lab, or whatever
it is you want to call it
for the larger system, I mean
that's the role we welcome.
And I think now because we've been
doing this for 10 years, in my mind,
it's time to get this out of
the Petri dish and out of the R
and D lab, and it's time
to take this to scale.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org